اكدت الامم المتحده ان النصف مليون سوري
دون ماوى وتسعين بالمئه من السوريين
يعيشون دون مستوى الفقر خصوصا بعد ان دمر
الزلزال 650 وحده سكنيه في سوريا واوضحت
الامم المتحده ان حاجات التاهيل العاجله
في سوريا تتراوح بين سبعه فاصله تسعه
مليار حسب البنك الدولي
و14.8 مليار مؤكده انا السوريين مهددون
بان يكونوا رهينه دائره الفقر والعنف
والكارثه الصحيه التي تشهدها المنطقه
انضم الينا من بروكس المراسل العربيه نور
الدين الفريضي اهلا بك نور الدين لو توضح
لنا ابرز ما جاء في هذه المعلومات وايضا
نتائج المؤتمر حتى الان لدعم سوريا وتركيا
يعني في هذه اللحظات يقوم المسؤولون
الاوروبيون بجمع الارقام والوعود التي
قدمتها الدول الاعضاء
وكذلك الدول غير الاوروبيه مثل دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي ودول المانحه الاخرى
الاتحاد الاوروبي وعد بانه سيقدم من
موازنته المشتركه مليار يورو
مساعده تركيا سواء كان في الشان الانساني
او التاهيل او اعاده الاعمار المفوضيه
الاوروبيه اي الاتحاد سيقدم موازنته
108 ملايين لدعم الشؤون الانسانيه في
سوريا هذا الفرق ابراهيم بين مليار لتركيا
ومئه مليون لسوريا يعكس
الفرق الكبير والشاسع جدا بين المقاربات
تجاه تركيا وتجاه سوريا حيث يحتفظ الاتحاد
الاوروبي او يذكر بان له دائما خطوط حمر
تعوق دون
مساعده سوريا بيتعلقوا باعاده الاعمال حيث
الاتحاد الاوروبي ملتزم برا لان لا تطبيعه
مع النظام ولا رفع للعقوبات ولا مشاركه
اوروبيه في اعاده الاعمال بقي ان الشان
الانساني هو يتعلق به ما هو معروف يعني
توفير الغذاء الادويه الخيام وايضا اعاده
تاهيل بعد شبكات المياه والمدارس وهذا تحت
اشراف الامم المتحده بشكل اساسي ولكن
ابراهيم دعني نستفيد من الدكتور عبد الله
الربيعي وهو المستشار الملكي والمشرف
العام على مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
الانسانيه ساعات الدكتور ما هي مساهمه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في هذا المؤتمر
لو سمحت طبعا المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اولا استجابت
لاثر الزلزال منذ ساعات الاولى بتوجيهات
خالد محرم الشريفين ولعهد الامين باولا
استجابه حكوميه بارسال فرق ميدانيه من
المركز من المدير العام للدفاع المدني
كذلك من هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي
وكانت الفرق الميدانيه تعتبر من اوائل
الفرق التي هبت لانقاذ المصابين في
الميدان كذلك التوجيه الكريم باطلاق حمله
شعبيه
لتاكيد مدى حرص حكومه خالد على
التقارب بين الحب ولذلك ساهمت ساهم
المواطنون السعوديون
بالاستجابه السريعه
لتوجيهات خالد محرم الشريفين
والى هذا اليوم
رصدت المملكه العربيه السعوديه هنا بينما
قدمت الدوله وما قدمه المتبرعون اكثر من
150 مليون دولار ولا زالت الحمله قائمه
الى هذه الساعه هذه الحمله سوف
تنفذ منها مشاريع كبيره المركز الان سوف
ينفذ مشاريع سريعه وبدا فيها باطلاق الجسر
الجوي منذ الساعات الاولى اكثر من 16
طائره وكذلك
مشاريع طبيه وايوائيه وكذلك غذائيه
الاهم بدا مركز الملك سلمان انفاذ الاتجاه
الكريم بالبدء في
ايواء اكثر من مؤقت او او افضل من الخيام
وهي انشاء مباني
مؤقته فيها الخدمات اللازمه اذا سمحت
الامم المتحده تقول بان نصف مليون سوري هم
اليوم دون ماوى وان الافاق يعني تقريبا
مظلمه بالنسبه للشعب السوري لانه مهدد
بالفقر بالعنف بالكارثه الصحيه حتى الكل
تهدد اليوم جزء من المواطنين السوريين
خاصه في المناطق المنكوبه
السعوديه في تعاملها الانساني مع ضحايا
الزلزال في سوريا او ضحايا الازمه كيف
تتعاملون
المملكه العربيه السعوديه اولا لم تفرق
بين
الشعبين السوري والتركي ونتعامل من خلال
اولا ايصال المساعدات المباشره طائرات
المملكه حطت في مطار حلب ولا زالت تنقل
المساعدات سواء كانت لحلب او المناطق
المتضرره او
الشمال الغربي السوري المملكه حريصه على
الشعب السوري لضمان اولا استقراره لضمان
وصول المساعدات لضمان الماوى السريع وان
شاء الله المستدام هذه الاستجابه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه حريصه على ان لا
تفرق بين الشعب السوري والشعب التركي
ايمانا باهميه تقارب الشعب السوري من من
المنظومه هناك مسائل حيويه جدا بالنسبه
للسوريين مثل مياه الصريح للشراب مثل
المدارس مثل السكن هل
يعني السعوديه قادره على ايصال هذه
المساعدات الى المنكوبين هل المساعدات
السعوديه تواجه ايضا عوائق مثل ما تقول
منظمات اوروبيه
طبعا اولا
وصلت
وخير من يشهد للمملكه العربيه السعوديه هو
الشعب السوري وصلنا
للمناطق مختلفه اوصلنا الخيام اوصلنا
المواد اللوائيه او وصلنا الغذاء اوصلنا
كذلك المواد الصحيه وكذلك الان ننفذ مع
شراء كلام شركاء لنا في الميدان
برامج صحيه اكثر استدامه وكذلك ما تحدثت
عنه وهو انشاء مباني 3000 وحده سكنيه نصف
هذه الوحدات السكانيه سوف تكون في سوريا
فالمملكه تصل لم نجد عوائق كبيره في
الوصول وان شاء الله اننا سوف نصل
المستهدفه والمتضرره من هذا الزلزال وكان
هنالك تعاون في الواقع من
هيئه الهلال الاحمر السوري مع مركز الملك
سلمان للغه الانسانيه واستجابه سريعه
وترخيص للطائرات السعوديه والفرق السعوديه
للوصول بشكل سريع انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر
والتوفيق ان شاء الله شكرا لك شكرا
ابراهيم المؤتمر سينتهي في غضون اللحظات
وستعلن المفوضيه الاوروبيه اي الرئيسه
ارسل وكذلك رئيس وزراء السويد عن نتائج
هذا المؤتمر من حيث الماليه ولكن للايداع
هناك وعود ماليه كبيره جدا تمنح لتركيا
سواء كانوا يتعلق بشان الانسان بعاده
التاهيل البني تحته او الشبكات والمباني
بالنسبه لتركيا بالنسبه لسوريا فان هذه
مساعده تستهدف بشكل اساسي الشان الانساني
واعاده التاهيل بمعنى شبكه المياه او
المدرسه او شكرا جزيلا لك نور الدين
الفريده مراسل العربيه
ايضا للدكتور عبد الله ربيع المشرف لعام
على مركز الملك سلمان الاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه